you
well there are many reasons why many
white Americans in particular were
shocked by what they saw with Reverend
Wright first of all the vast ignorance
and unfamiliarity with black life
it was Fannie Lou Hamer the great socio
activists and civil rights leader who
said the mistake many white people made
is that they put black people behind
them so when black people were put
behind them for our survivals sake we
understood the rituals the folkways the
mores the habits the dispositions the
skills the abilities the excellencies
and the flaws of white America we knew
when to speak when not to speak we knew
what was part of the culture and if you
extended to the day we had to watch
friends we knew what that was about
but white America didn't have to watch
living single so that for our sanity and
survival black people and other
minorities have to know white America
have to know what turns them on what
turns them off what sparks their
imagination what gives them a sense of
what Aviv and what depresses them and
and we have to gauge ourselves
accordingly something that many white
Americans don't even have to be
conscious of or think about and it shows
we know much about the white church many
black people but many white brothers and
sisters don't know about minority
religious traditions and it is shocking
that it was shocking that what reverend
wright was said was shocking that you
know this is something that passes for
you know pretty much the the standard
fare among the great prophetic preachers
now that's saying that that's not saying
that dr. Wright is not an extraordinary
exemplar of that tradition which he is
but for the most part when you go into a
prophetic black church where black
pastors are the conduits of cultural
criticism and social critique lodged at
a dominant Society because they are the
freest members of our community still
they are not dependent upon white
corporate support for their churches for
the most part they are free and
independent thinkers who are paid by
their own members to say what does they
have the Lord and also to give a kind of
ongoing and continuing state of the race
argument in their sermons so we see the
fusion of Holy Ghost of theology with
what happens with the gas tax we see a
relationship between the sacred and the
secular
our religious traditions in terms of our
sermons and homilies are constant
commentaries upon cultural you know
landmines and social landscapes that
need to be addressed and social problems
and issues and ills that need to be
addressed so there's nothing weird about
having black ministers speak about
social injustice about what's going on
in Iraq but about what's happening in
Iran about what happens with war
speaking about how aids get created and
what some of the theories are and some
of the conspiracy theories are or to
talk about white supremacy social
injustice economic inequality that stuff
is par for the course I'm an ordained
Baptist minister I've been a reverend
since 1979 that is the tradition on
which I cut my teeth so the vast
ignorance about that is pretty
remarkable but it does reinforce the
fact that we live as listing Pope the
Dean of Yale Divinity School said years
ago that dr. King liked to quote the
most segregated hour in America is still
11:00 a.m. on Sunday morning black
people going in their churches Latinos
going to their churches wife are going
in their churches black folk over here
and and so on and as a result of that
there's you know never the twain shall
meet and the tragedy of that of course
is that we don't know you know we don't
understand and worship with each other
and many white Americans just don't
understand what goes on a black church
is I dare say to you that when most
black people heard that Jeremiah Wright
sermon they said uh did we miss the part
that was bad
you know maybe they played it fast maybe
we didn't hear let me see uh rich white
people run America oh oh okay
did we miss the memo was it the poor
Puerto Ricans oh maybe it's the
Dominicans this week oh how about poor
black people no not them hey maybe white
Appalachians who are poor no not them
guess what rich white people in terms of
presidents and governors and Senators
and corporate chieftains they've pretty
much run America
so that was an uncontroversial to us the
notion of aids being cooked up in a
laboratory somewhere to be spread as a
virus to degrade and destroy black
America it's not so much that black
people have to agree with that
the larger point being made there that
the imagination can scarcely capture
what actually happens in America so that
conspiracy has to fill in the blanks
because we we know that something
nefarious in file has historically
occurred in black America in regard to
science I mean who would think that
white Americans would allow black people
unbeknownst to them to have run out in
the course through its full course in
their bodies
syphilis without telling them they're
unwitting guinea pigs of course that
would never happen not in America but it
did so suspicion and skepticism
generated by black America tort that
made us listen to Reverend Wright and go
well yeah uh you know the Tuskegee
Experiment was real and plus the last
famous black person to say that was a
guy named Bill Cosby and Bill Cosby in
the 90s put that theory for if he said
AIDS was created to get rid of people
that people don't like he said that in
the 90s in the New York Post and on
television so III think that when we
look at what Reverend Wright was saying
and terror we don't have to look beyond
the borders of America to understand
that terror didn't begin for black
people on 9/11 how about sixteen
nineteen twenty slaves brought to you
know Jamestown and thus beginning the
slave trade here the broader expanding
and evolving American Empire the
hegemony of Western imperialism all of
this stuff is taken for our for the
course and our preachers speak about
that because we live in a society where
historically the freest and most
educated person in the community was the
pastor that's no longer the truth in
terms of at least education now we have
corporate chieftains we have political
figures going on Ivy League schools
although many of the ministers have had
that advantage as well but when when
when there was a time when the ministers
were educated because they had to go to
school in Theological Seminary or have
some kind of formal education about the
Bible and theology they were the
lettered to turgid people of the
community vast realms of eloquence were
at their disposal and they deployed them
with edifying grace and power and
luminous intelligence to highlight
underscore and
grasp hold of of the most confounding
problems in black America so when we see
that many white Americans were shocked
it's distressing because it just
suggests they still haven't come to
grips with the vast majority of black
people who go to church and the styles
of black worship well yeah now after
white America gets scared they're theirs
but if you're like oh my Jesus I thought
they were talking about Jesus didn't
know they were they talking about stuff
like they're talking about well we talk
about Jesus too we love Jesus at the
black church I love the Lord he heard my
cry and pitied every moan long as I live
in trouble rise out hasten to his throne
so we still talk about that but we also
include the other stuff because we don't
think in the black church that if you're
talking about Jesus but not about the
mortgage crisis in the prophetic black
church that you're really doing your job
and I think it is an opportunity for
education all around because it's not
just white brothers and sisters black
folk to some of whom were distressed by
that got a lesson and the the vast
majority of Americans associate now
black religion some would say
fortunately many would say unfortunately
with creflo dollar at it's brilliant
eloquent oratorical peak with the TD
jakes
but the prophetic black church has been
obscured and so yeah it came roaring
back and loudly articulated in the voice
of Jeremiah Wright but there are many
others
dr. Freddie Haynes in Dallas Texas dr.
Charles Gilchrist Adams in Detroit dr.
William Curtis in Pittsburgh dr. Lance
Watson in Virginia in in in in a very
powerful way in a young man who shared
ministry with me in Detroit and many
more
dr. Vashti Mackenzie a bishop
and when you think about these figures
these are prophetic figures who
articulate a serious and sustained
vision of african-american possibility
and the way in which America must heal
heed and yield to the prophetic voices
of people whose blood has been mixed
with the soil of America to produce what
we are sprouting from that blood-soaked
soil have been some of the most powerful
embodiments of the ideals of America so
it's an insult to suggest that black
people who criticize the nation are not
patriots I mean Martin King jr. and many
others in the prophetic black church
practice critical patriotism and
critical patriotism says we love the
country enough to tell the truth but we
don't make this mistake for the most
part between in blurring the division
between nationalism and patriotism
nationalism is the uncritical
valorisation and celebration of one's
country right or wrong regardless I'm
with it it's right I don't care what you
think we're going to go for this kind of
cowboy imperialism that is embedded
embedded and embodied quite frankly in
the Bush administration before that in
the Reagan administration
in a way that it was a new western
frontier and America was the galloping
you know horse that delivered the
message of freedom for the rest of the
world hmm so that this silver bullet
that we thought we could dispense from
our machinery what somehow you know
darkened the world globally and be able
to deliver a message of redemption and
hope and many people saw it as a message
of terror
another thing ribbon write said oh my
god are we denying at America that we've
done some things that have been quite
inept inequities iniquitous and
certainly ultimately visiting terror
upon other nations and other people's my
god we've done it to Native Americans
here in America we've done it in terms
of genocidal impulses toward our First
Nations people and slavery for African
American people this heinous Holocaust
of hurt and heartbreak and suffering has
to be grappled with in dealt with the
the enslavement literally physically and
spiritually of so many despotic aliy
ruled over minority and vulnerable
people
so all of that which is to say it's an
opportunity for us to open up to talk
about nationalism on the one hand versus
patriotism which is the critical support
of one's nation by looking at it in
light of its best values if these best
values of democracy freedom justice and
truth prevail then America is beautiful
and good when it contradicts those ideas
for which it has been willing to fight
then they must be called on the carpet
of conscience so to speak and done so in
love but vigorously and I think this is
a grand opportunity to learn more about
the black church to learn more about its
values its virtues its visions about its
visionaries about its voice pieces and
about those people who articulate with
logic rigor and clarity of the
aspirations of the masses of black
people